[Music]
in city art news shitty art art oh hey
Nike slippers oh I love like I just one
of those slides and now we're the
grandma slides
I like regular flip-flops I like shoes
an artist who uses moose poop as her
medium is overwhelmed by demand I don't
wanna get you guys for your birthday's
that's so funny
what's wrong it's like the [ __ ] Sacha
Baron Cohen's [ __ ] the [ __ ] it is
his feces canvas why man he's making fun
of these people what is he a genius he
the Sasha's a genius she is a genius but
he's making fun of these people I can't
wait to get my hands on some [ __ ] that's
what some of these people are thinking
she good think she gets very excited
what you see the whole pile of turd I
think what's wrong with crayons yeah
okay we can help you we can be some
prismo prison was our good yeah what's
wrong some [ __ ]
markers yeah Charlie so old everyone's
already found out of it really oh yeah
show you guys a video of Mary
well that's gonna wasis you good one man
it was on airplane mode
that's my was it it was not do not
disturb you asked me if it sounds dude
did i disturb you and then the wife I
keep using it tell me let me know which
ones you want so I could I want you to
put airplane our options were disturb
airplay oh no everything but no Wi-Fi
silence just light it off for a battle
that's it did leave it at home is this
what you wanted this is what she wants
to play music - no no music our work
filming time to light flashlights on
that's our tell me one thing I didn't do
it so you can't blame me but I told you
in the beginning so it covers every take
do not ever take air attacks get the new
iPhone access do it the rest max and
then you you're eating do you really
need it yeah okay so let me show you
this video of Mary everyoneís it's a
poop moose poop those are little mice or
something I did that with Donuts this
[ __ ] cheatin ass [ __ ] doughnut biter
bro why she put that weird like that
smells like [ __ ] Christmas desserts
pretty sure does kitchen counter like
every well what does she eat up everyone
takes a crap everyone goes to the
bathroom so everyone can relate to that
and every term that I use to name these
products or everyday terms that you know
people are used to hearing and stuff so
it just kind of she's dog turd
fertilization kids I mean you know for
example the first thing that we make now
instead of a cuckoo clock see this is a
poopoo clock this is like a Dave
Chappelle's kid right there we can do
with big boobs or guts or butts a long
legs a short like see cuz there's no two
turns under ever light you ever seen a
turn the two turns along no the turn
snot-nose yeah in your face is what
she's saying they're gonna take a crap
and hi I have found that when a moose
takes a dump you walk about 50 yards in
any direction and they take another dump
mean page right there with the prices
and click on them and then get to me and
let me know what you need for turns and
I ship everywhere okay I was picturing
something totally different
I was picturing some [ __ ] weird ass
person with a beret and a long ass
[ __ ] cigarette like this and their
pretentious ass well these people don't
exist and they're talking about [ __ ]
like how they were inspired by like the
current [ __ ] political climate and
they wanted to do some pretentious ass
[ __ ] art this lady I will [ __ ]
spend trillions of dollars for mark
Martin Bird wouldn't miss Olympus yeah
it is literally somebody who has nothing
else to do and they are bored out of
their mind and this is what happens
because I've because so my friend was in
Ecuador for two years and this fool
would send me mail written by hand
- this guy literally had no friend out
there because I've never seen him write
so much in my life and he expected me to
read best [ __ ] hey by the way bro why
did he text you or something
he had no nothing you could just all you
had to do was write letters and then
finally in candle and [ __ ] yeah so so
finally what he got like internet and
Wi-Fi was kind of facetiming I was like
dude the [ __ ] why'd you write me a
script handwritten dude because I want
you to make this I'm not making this
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] you wrote a
script by hand so I can make it on my
channel and it was straight trash Marius
is 57 years old she's dope dude I want
your poop this is like she'll set up her
stand and a lot of like craft fair -
monster fairs crap yeah moose turd she's
she's hilarious man I could see why
people are buying this though petition
petition to Webster's dictionary to
change the spelling of the word turd to
t.i why she believes that it should be
spelled with an i turds I like birds
birds and turns to 33 33 30 what it yeah
and then that's so close it to 30
Christmas tree it's not like [ __ ] though
cuz you know like she says that she came
home with like a special solution to not
make them smell okay and then like
summer products I'm fecal people oh well
you know what the earth herbivores their
poop isn't that bad like when you smell
like horse [ __ ] or whatever like cash
it's kind of nasty but then like when
you're in the full rest and then there
just so happens to be a poop of not of
an encore
a non carnivorous animal and it's a
herbivore it doesn't smell that bad yeah
yes true like dog [ __ ] smells bad
dog [ __ ] is horrible man especially the
ones that baked you out like you see it
right and it looks crusted on the
outside so you're like like a [ __ ] of
roasted marshmallows shmore and then you
go okay cool this one solid a leprechaun
green pick it up right and then it
cracks and then the inside foods is out
you're like what the [ __ ] this was
supposed to be solid dude what the hairs
all over your fingers did you pick it up
by your hand sorry Vince always a
catalyst I always breathe out of my
mouth I don't know what I don't know
that smells you're a mouth-breather then
dude I just imagine that [ __ ] [ __ ]
air going into my mouth dude because
what i do is i go i beat through the
shirt filter yeah it helps doing traitor
d yeah should you [ __ ] melt meat I
love that liners dirty rat yeah you love
that line if you look at Connor McGrady
goes shut your [ __ ] me out meet me I
love karma crap tell these hands bro hmm
it's funny how there's like tons of
people selling [ __ ] literal [ __ ] and
making money like remember the Dookie
deliver like you wanna [ __ ] prank
somebody yeah yeah yeah you just [ __ ]
deliver [ __ ] yeah this woman she's been
selling moose poop art for 15 years we
really got to make mother duck duck
goose dude this that this isn't a sign
dude [ __ ] this isn't a [ __ ] sign yep
I want some explain to people that don't
know what that goose is the dumbest
[ __ ] idea we've ever had that we
should have done years ago it's
basically every [ __ ] stupid thing
that we think of upon t-shirt right here
sold
oh you call it nuts [ __ ] Yeah right
there I start the bid
five hundred dollars there you go nuts
[ __ ] 100%
we just have shirts [ __ ] mugs [ __ ]
[ __ ] origami [ __ ] Oregon antic
Japanese origami right here handmade by
a Japanese man with the plastic on your
pinky origami every shirt at auction yep
will sell like will sell some expensive
[ __ ] like a gold coin for under the
value and we'll sit we'll sell this
spoon for like fifty thousand dollars
because I I licked it everybody like
this once now it's gonna be just
anything and everything Bart has an
array of like masterpieces such as that
painting on the wall that I have a lot
of designs that that's that's like the
display art like he's got a lot of
designs that he's ready to kind of
unload into the world like a [ __ ]
special and yeah I feel like there's a
lot of things we can constantly come up
with you know pubic hair trimmings
half-eaten bag of a potato chip bag
trash it's memorabilia yeah
it's art they're props yeah I miss the
days when I could just understand art I
could just look at something to say
that's [ __ ] dope now I don't know
what it's too hard man that [ __ ] uh
not LACMA but the the gate Yoga Getty Oh
Betty I've been in Getty oh I hate
Modern Art actually makes me angry
MOCA was good the broad museum did the
broad I'm sorry the broad Road it's
[ __ ] stupid dude like I've never seen
such trash in my life dude you know the
rooms of
hmm I did see this cool contraption
though like I walked into one of those
like modern art display things and then
there were a bunch of scissors that were
hanging from that with a little scissors
there were Little Caesars beaks Caesars
and somehow there's a sensor that
follows you and the scissors they start
[ __ ] going like so if you walk
straight this way the scissor is going
anyway yeah and I'm like that [ __ ]
dog that's scary yeah it made me [ __ ]
start going in circles and in all the
citizens going I literally saw this art
piece where it was just a [ __ ] like
red circle and it was like worth a
gajillion dollars as I [ __ ] on a day
with that [ __ ] dude you dumb [ __ ]
bladder one come on
abstract art or the charcoal dicks
somebody just took a piece of chocolate
do like seven dicks which all of us have
done at one point our lives that is
worth like a kajillion dollars yeah well
that's what it's probably the rich
people you were talking about Joe yeah
that's what you're a pig Circle it
around and they just up the value and
there's no real you see these people
just sitting there like this yeah hmm
I understand I wanted to slap them
upside what if they were just talking
about what we're gonna eat oh absolutely
not
mmm they were just like this that's odd
that's beautiful I understand it I
understand it yeah I can understand the
artists angst I will [ __ ] you up so bad
I just wanted to punch them upside the
head so hard you know
I don't I don't know like when I look at
that it's supposed to make you feel
something right yeah I feel anger it's
one note it's always one note I looked
at you they were like God in [ __ ] this
dude and in no other like art medium
though is this like the premium people
you know to me like in music right you
have all those weird experimental people
that are like super I just like high
frequency sounds and like you know the
you know the weird ones right but
they're like everyone's like the [ __ ]
you guys are weird like have your little
circle jerk open mic nights and then
it's just weird no one cares about that
they don't they're not the top yeah in
art though it's the opposite
those guys are like the top top guys
making [ __ ] millions of dollars and
[ __ ] and you're like why that's like
that's like if you get ty cut it start
drawing some [ __ ] that's the same thing
that's yeah a teiko original that's the
same [ __ ] we just got to pull the canvas
away from him right before he tears it
in half oh yeah and then he goes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]